the latest is that the Prime Minister
Boris Johnson is on the ground here in
North Derbyshire assessing the damage to
the dam and offering his support to the
people of Whaley Bridge who of course
have been through the most extraordinary
24 hours and this one of the first
visits by the prime minister in
unscheduled terms I suppose a visit that
of course has been hastily arranged
given the gravity of the situation in
this part of Derbyshire and these are
live pictures of the Prime Minister on
the ground here in Derbyshire tonight
and it is of course a visit to offer
support and resource and there are many
many questions that he will be out he
may or may not be able to answer
questions around infrastructure just
what are the checks on these kinds of
bits of infrastructure more pressingly
for the people of Whaley Bridge just
what can be done to make sure that
everything possible is being done to
save this reservoir all day we've been
seeing the RAF working with that she
looked helicopter it's still going on in
the background this evening behind us as
we